we all know Hagrid is the Paragon of
gentle Giants but can the same be said
for the late actor who played him Robbie
Coltrane HBO Max rang in 2022 with an
incredible release for fans debuting a
Harry Potter reunion special featuring
all your favorite actors and plenty of
reminiscing about what it was like to
make this epic eight film franchise in
particular the younger set of actors who
grew up on the set had a lot of
Revelations about what it was like to
work with the adult cast members many of
whom are some of the most decorated
performers in British film and
television history from Maggie Smith to
Helena Bonham Carter to actors who sadly
passed away like Richard Harris Richard
Griffiths and Alan Rickman the then
child actors had the opportunity to work
with some of the best living actors of
their time Chris Columbus director of
the first two Potter movies tells
audiences during the reunion I don't
think any of the kids had the capability
of understanding the gravity of who they
were dealing with at the time the
British royalty of the acting World
among those giant names one person got a
ton of shout outs Coltrane who shared a
ton of scenes with Radcliffe Watson and
Grint in particular Watson recalled the
adult actors came in and were like the
Mischief in a funny way speaking
specifically about Coltrane Grint said
he was such a kid like so immature and
like
just so much fun Radcliffe accompanied
by a video of Coltrane doing a super
silly voice said he loved making us
laugh and he was incredibly good at it
after that the reunion brought Watson
and Coltrane together who shared a hug
and snapped a photo before reminiscing
about their time on set as Watson
pointed out the two spent a lot of time
together filming in Hagrid's Hut and
Coltrane even admitted that he probably
saw the trio more than his own children
even after 20 years the bond between
Coltrane and the trio was as strong as
ever and his as Watson points out warmth
and kindness made all of the difference
for the young actors Daniel Radcliffe
felt so comfortable on the Harry Potter
sets with Robbie Coltrane initially that
he decided to prank his co-star when
appearing on the Rosie O'Donnell show in
the early Arts Coltrane told the talk
show host about how Radcliffe got a hold
of his phone and made some adjustments
so he had no idea how to work it a very
young Radcliffe was there as the story
was told and couldn't help but chuckle
Coltrane remembered this one here turned
the language on my cell your phone into
Turkish he then laughed that it would
have been easy to switch it back to
English but you must know Turkish to do
that according to hollywood.com
Radcliffe felt terrible about the prank
afterward and wrote Coltrane a note to
apologize these types of interviews and
the HBO Max Harry Potter reunion special
proved just how special the late
Coltrane was to the rest of the cast and
the fans of the franchise Coltrane said
the legacy of the movies is that my
children's generation will show them to
their children so you could be watching
in 50 years time easy and then just to
make sure no one is exempt from [ __ ]
at least one tear he poignantly
concluded I'll not be here sadly but I
did well yes
[Music]